we really
you
it's a beautiful day to be alive you bad
[__] uncle Joey here checking
in with you [__] making sure
everything is on the straight and narrow
you understand me the sun's out the
birds are chirping you got another day
the sling dick and give our bubblegum
you understand me take it to your
[__] home turf anyway I got a couple
of things going on today
I got acupuncture I got to talk to a few
people but a dog I gotta go to [__]
the store tonight with Skylar Stone show
and my week is [__] over Friday
starts the birthday weekend 54 I'm still
here I can't believe it myself people
you understand me but what are you gonna
do you got a [__] embrace it you know
I'm saying how do I get here I have no
[__] idea balls and heart I'm telling
you right now all that other [__] is
[__] balls and harp enjoy what's
with the [__] ear beat this morning
we got a spark or 1 let's [__] kill
this mule we still got some classical g4
from perennial and we still got some
presidential from Sunset herbal killing
[__] you understand me this is
the [__] trunk should be smoking he'll
make better [__] decisions but who
gives a [__] about that we still gotta
go out there and swing dick and do our
[__] job you understand me let's fill
this little thing up here this little
[__] couscous if you're an immigrant
you didn't go to work today
[__] that [__] well what for breakfast
there was immigrants everywhere only
little college Mexicans then go to work
so everybody else went to work
old-school Mexicans ain't got time to
[__] around and go on CNN they don't
know nothing about this [__]
Armenians they're at work today they
don't give a [__] somebody's getting cut
off right now by in Armenia while these
are the [__] dudes they're at home
you know
let's join for solidarity suck my dick
and call me shorty all right I gotta pay
my bills my go-to supermarket ain't no
solidarity
the else--but so for right now I gotta
go to work I gotta take care when I
gotta take care and I have your money
and get some [__] brief Illinois am i
bullshitting you you gotta get money to
get reefer
you gotta justify your [__] existence
oh this is the [__] that killed Prince
speaking of Prince I'll be up in
Minneapolis next week at the house at
Comley a week from tonight smoking
eating stars doing our thing freezing
the [__] deck but it don't matter it
don't [__] matter Minneapolis is
where it's at next Thursday [__]
night the house of [__] comedy at the
Mall of America
Isis stay away don't even [__] around
that night I'm not in the mood to deal
with you [__] let's try a little
bit of this classic OG to get them the
blood vessels gone you don't say Harry
come in come say hello Harry Harry Harry
come say hello these savages come here
Harry
you don't like reefer Harry baby's gonna
come over say it alone
[Music]
we think of this was my little beast
Harry this as good as it gets people
there's no cat is look at that face he's
dead you understand me
he's gonna go you don't like reefer
he's clean and sober he never even
[__] dabbled you understand me but
what we doing here let's smoke a bowl
this night you met Harry and we get the
party started
come here what you doing what you doing
papa it's my boy that's my [__] heart
you understand me I love my little
[__] cats that's what it's all about
reaching out sometimes you get a cat you
know they always say you rescue cats and
[__] sometimes but cat rescues you
believe in them Sam lets you find out
that they say you that that you didn't
know you [__] die
these [__] planes interrupted me
should they dawn with you people
and they said [__] spy planes these
concept isn't it
woo well anyway I'm here I'm queer I
just wanna check in with you cop
something's you know I love you and
that's it you got your two podcast you
got [__] Mazda vow and my man [__]
now what's his name
Tom roads you know you got it that's it
will be back [__] Monday morning but
I'll check in with you [__] over
the weekend I tell ya I'm stone for the
girls I gotta go to acupuncture now I'm
gonna feel every [__] needle it's
like torture but I don't give a [__]
that I gotta overcome that fear
I love you [__] stay black uncle
Joey gotcha it's Thursday but don't mean
[__] you still got to go out there and
represent on a daily set 24/7 you
swingin dick and giving our bubble bill
show mercy to nobody as long as you're
[__] on top that's all that [__]
matters every day's a struggle it's like
a jungle sometimes it makes me wonder
how I keep from going under so go for it
today today's your lucky [__] day
whatever happened yesterday and Tuesday
will give us a [__] today's the day you
got a strap on a pair go out there the
[__] desk and go who's drinking
yum yum from the [__] helmet of life
today that's your date today I love you
[__] stay black
Uncle Joe we got your back next week
Minneapolis to see these still on iTunes
the whole [__] thing in it's all up
to you now go out there stab a
[__]
today's your lucky day I love you stay
black
I got you